nine years ago when facebook bought
instagram for one billion dollars many
industry leaders were skeptical about
the decision
facebook themselves had just become
profitable a few years ago and they
hadn't even gone public yet so it didn't
seem very reasonable to spend one
billion dollars on a photo sharing app
that had only been around for one and a
half years with a total of 13 employees
with time however facebook's decision to
acquire instagram has proven to be a
brilliant business decision as instagram
is estimated to be worth a whopping 100
billion dollars today given that
facebook did not create instagram though
what happened to instagram's founders
and why did they leave facebook in 2018
well starting off with mike kryger mike
was born on march 4 1986 in sao paulo
brazil
we don't really know much about his
early life but it does seem like mike
excelled at school as he would be
admitted into stanford in 2004
at stanford mike majored in symbolic
systems and he would later meet kevin
systrom the other founder of instagram
during a fellowship when the two
eventually started working on instagram
mike mainly managed the technical side
of instagram he would fix outages make
sure there was enough server capacity
and so on and so forth one time mike
says that when he woke up in the morning
he saw an email saying that instagram
had gone down he instantly opened the
app to see what was going on when he
noticed that instagram was running
perfectly fine mike asked kevin and some
early employees if they had fixed the
issues but none of them had confused
mike decided to look at the terminal to
see who had made the last edit and it
turns out that mike had actually woken
up at 3 30 a.m fixed the outage and had
gone back to sleep clearly instagram's
operations weren't perfect but this
would all change when facebook bought
instagram in late 2012. owning 10 of the
company mike made a total of a 100
million dollars from the acquisition
assuming that mike's payout was
proportional to the overall acquisition
mike received 30 million dollars in cash
and 70 million dollars in facebook stock
facebook agreed to keep instagram a
separately run business so mike and
kevin maintained relative autonomy but
the financial technological and human
resources they received from facebook
were invaluable
after the acquisition mike became the
cto of instagram where he scaled the
engineering team from just six general
developers to 300 specialized engineers
one of the first projects that the team
worked on after the acquisition was
launching a web browser version of
instagram this was one of the first
times that a mobile app was translated
into a website usually it was the other
way around
anyway later in april of 2015 mike
partnered with a charity organization
called to give well where he donated 750
thousand dollars in 2016 mike worked on
redesigning the app to better match
modern ui and design it and in 2018 mike
worked on launching igtv at this point
it seemed like things were going great
instagram's user base was growing
exponentially and instagram was
transitioning from an up-and-coming
startup to an established social media
player yet just a couple of months after
the launch of igtv in september of 2018
mike and kevin announced that they would
be leaving instagram and facebook but
before we get into that let's take a
look at kevin's side of the story up
until this point kevin systrom was born
on december 30th 1983 in holliston
massachusetts as a kid kevin often
played a video game called doom 2 which
fueled an interest in programming kevin
would also end up attending stanford for
his bachelors but kevin majored in
management science and engineering while
at stanford kevin was selected to take
part in the mayfield fellows program
which not only allowed him to meet mike
but also score an internship at odeo if
you're not familiar with odeo these are
actually the guys who would go on to
create twitter anyway kevin didn't jump
straight into instagram or bourbon as it
was originally called right after
college in 2006 kevin actually joined
google as an associate product marketing
manager
at google kevin worked on google
calendar gmail docs and cheats a few
years into his venture at google a
couple of his co-workers left the
company to create their own company
called next stop
next up was a social travel
recommendation site and kevin would
follow his co-workers and join the
startup kevin didn't work at next stop
for too long but his experience with the
startup was essential in the creation of
instagram fun fact next stop was
acquired by facebook as well in 2010
after his tint and next stop kevin would
go around silicon valley and pitches
idea for bourbon to a plethora of
venture capitalists and recent horowitz
and baseline ventures would agree to
invest 500 000 into the idea and this
allowed kevin and mike to get bourbon
off the ground
initially bourbon was actually a
check-in app that allowed users to share
their location post pictures and
accumulate points
however kevin soon decided that it was
better to just focus on one feature and
this led to the creation of instagram
instagram was a rather trendy launch as
the app basically went viral immediately
within the first 24 hours 25 000 people
signed up for instagram and within 9
months instagram boasted a total of 7
million users meanwhile facebook's user
growth had stalled and many users had
even stopped using facebook so mark
zuckerberg made a gutsy move to play it
big with instagram kevin also received
an offer from jack dorsey as well but
their offer was only half of facebook's
offer and 500 million dollars kevin also
had plenty of private funding as well
which could run the company for years
but he felt that support from facebook
would largely streamline the process he
didn't want to lose control though so he
put in a contingency that instagram
would operate as an independent company
facebook would agree and the kevin would
remain the ceo of instagram under the
ownership of facebook the acquisition
netted kevin a total of 400 million
dollars and if we assume that the ratio
of cash to stock is the same as the
overall acquisition kevin received 120
million dollars in cash and 280 million
dollars in facebook stock under kevin's
leadership we saw the release of a
variety of different filters the story
goes that kevin's girlfriend did not
want to post pictures from their
vacation to mexico because she didn't
like the quality of the pictures kevin's
solution to this conundrum was designing
filters that could effectively disguise
the quality of the pictures nowadays
this isn't really that big of a concern
considering how advanced smartphone
cameras have become nonetheless filters
have become a staple of instagram today
aside from filters kevin also oversaw
the release of the explore tab and the
monetization of instagram and in may of
2017 kevin described how he envisioned
instagram getting involved with virtual
reality products within the next few
years so clearly he had no intentions of
leaving the company at this time
yet he would do just that a year later
so
what happened
well neither mike kevin nor mark had
really pointed any fingers at each other
publicly mark simply congratulated mike
and kevin on their success and wished
them good luck in their future endeavors
meanwhile mike and kevin simply stated
that they were ready to move on to new
ventures in reality though it seems like
there was much more going on behind the
scenes you see though instagram's
autonomy allowed kevin and mike to
retain control of instagram and grow it
how they wanted it also created a divide
within facebook a lot of facebook's
executives felt that instagram was
outshining facebook and that facebook
should get more credit for instagram
success
i don't think mark was part of this
group as i think he was proud and happy
that he made a great call with instagram
but he didn't want to upset the
executives that were butthurt so he
started to impose limitations on
instagram and take more credit for
instagram success in the july 2018
earnings call for instance mark stated
quote we believe instagram has been able
to use facebook's infrastructure to grow
more than twice as quickly as it would
have on its own soon after mark asked
his head of growth to make a list of all
the ways facebook supported and boosted
instagram's growth mark would then go
ahead and inform kevin and mike that he
has to take away all these supports in
order to protect the facebook app around
the same time kevin participated in some
magazine profiles and mark would go
ahead and ban facebook employees from
participating in magazine profiles
without approval from himself or cheryl
sandberg who is the ceo of facebook
irritated by all of these new rules
kevin would use paternity leave as an
excuse to take a break from instagram
for a little bit but mark continued to
push kevin's buttons while kevin was on
leave mark started testing location
tracking on instagram something kevin
was strongly against by this point kevin
became convinced that mark was trying to
make kevin's life as miserable as
possible in order to force him to resign
this was also around the same time that
facebook was involved in the cambridge
analytica scandal which just further put
off kevin and mike so the duo took the
hint and resigned from instagram shortly
after kevin returned from paternity
leave adam missouri took over as the new
leader of the company and instagram has
been doing just fine since then however
it does seem like instagram has lost the
autonomy that it once said kevin did
eventually hint at this tension between
himself and mark by stating no one ever
leaves a job because everything is
awesome
anyway since their departure kevin and
mike have taken it easy opting to focus
on their families hobbies and
self-improvement the biggest thing the
duo has embarked on since leaving
instagram has been rt.live the duo
launched his website in april of 2020
and the website provided up-to-date data
on how fast cover 19 was spreading in
each state if you go to rt.live now
though you'll see that the website has
been shut down due to better tracking
methods being available
but that's pretty much it from mike and
kevin
after the acquisition the duo took on
leading roles at instagram for many
years instagram's expansion was going
great and instagram became a leading
social media company however their
explosive success ended up being the
root of their downfall instagram's
autonomy began to slowly erode and
eventually kevin and mike had had enough
and they left the company it's not all
bad though since then they've been
taking it easy finally enjoying the
wealth they earned years ago do you guys
think facebook's acquisition of
instagram was a positive or negative
long term comment that down below
also drop a like if you use instagram
way too much and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one